I was a kid you famously worked for Sid
Caesar and when I was in my truck you
were near my cut
come here you get him I didn't take my
medicine today oh okay
[Laughter]
he doesn't work he doesn't work for us
nah just a guy in the crowd wearing a
headset you you work for Sid Caesar on a
great show your show of shows and I've
heard there's a story that he was
physically very strong very strong
you know man and that you experienced
that more than any anybody else I I went
to Chicago sit at a gig in the second
year of the show of shows and when we
had our hiatus in Chicago at the Palmer
House in the Empire room it was good too
but he wanted more jokes and we were up
in his room and he was smoking cigars
and I and it was 2:00 in the morning and
I said we can air Aaron he said air air
I can't the cigar smoke of my kid and he
said air and said and I had a vodka or
two or maybe 16 I don't know any he went
to the window air you want air and a
windows probably was shut for 40 years
you know anyone bang and it was open and
then he grabbed me by the collar and by
the pants and he held me over Michigan
Avenue air like
we're having yeah yeah
and I'm looking I see taxicabs I said
yeah he said enough buy all plenty I've
had an affair yeah and he took me he
took me back inside while we're in
Chicago we scraped him we rented a car
and we scraped a taxicab and they have a
little leather bowtie in a yellow cap
the Chicago cab drivers and the cab
driver said you son of a [ __ ] in his
curtain and I said oh my god oh you
don't say son of a [ __ ] - Sid Caesar
you'd simply don't because he's not only
the funniest comic but also the
strongest comic ya in the world so he
walks over to the cab drivers cab and he
says uh I want to talk to you about your
birth I want to talk to you remember how
money were born can you have any memory
the kid drives looking at him like he's
gay rolls up his window but he leaves
that little clipper window open you know
there used to be a window yeah pray a
little vent window yeah and so Sid he
says that can you remember anything
about your birth I think I says what are
you crazy and he says don't worry about
it we're gonna reenact and he grabs him
right I let the boats I starts pulling
him out of that Clipper window it would
have been one spaghetti I'm again
had a buddy we were reenact it was very
strong he was very and very talented
most comics you wrote for I wrote for
you prayed that they met your material
that they just did it yeah
Sid always raised it so nice painted for
everyone said he was the best instrument
yeah to hear your music thrilled he was
the best he was